can we step back to Kepler
1625b what is it and you you've talked
about this kind of Journey this
effort to discover uh EXO moons so moons
out there or small cool objects out
there uh where does that effort stand
and what is coupler 1625b yeah we I mean
I've been searching for Max amendments
for most of my professional career and I
think a lot of my colleagues think I'm
kind of crazy to to still be doing it
you know after
after five years of not finding anything
I think most people would probably try
doing something else I even had people
say that to me they said um you know
professors and I remember the cocktail
party took me to the side an MIT
Professor he said
um you know you should just look for hot
Jupiters they're everywhere it's really
you can write papers they're so easy to
find and I was like yeah but hardship
just just they're not interesting to me
I want to do something that I feel
intellectually pushes me to the edge and
there's maybe a contribution that not no
one else could do but maybe
um is not certainly the thing that
anybody could do I don't want to just be
the first to something for the sake of
being first I want to do something that
feels like a meaningful intellectual
contribution to our society and so you
know this examine problem has been
haunting me for years to try and solve
this now as I said we looked for years
and years using Kepler
and the closest we ever got was just a
hint for this one star Kepler 1625 has a
Jupiter like planet in orbit of it and
that Jupiter planet is on a 287 day
period so it's almost the same distance
as the Earth around the Sun but for a
Jupiter
um so that was already unusual I don't
think people realize that Jupiter like
planets are quite rare in the universe
certainly many Neptunes and Neptunes are
extremely common but Jupiter is only
about 10 of sun-like stars have Jupiters
around them as far as we can tell when
you say Jupiter which aspect of Jupiter
in terms of its mass and uh it's a major
access so anything beyond about half an
au so half the distance of the Earth and
the Sun and something of order of um a
tenth of a Jupiter Mass that's the mass
of Saturn up to say 10 Jupiter masses
which is basically where you start to
get to Brown dwarfs those types of
objects appear to be somewhat unusual
most solar systems do not have Jupiters
which is really interesting because
Jupiter again like the moon seems to
have been a pivotal character in the
story of the development of our solar
system perhaps especially having a large
influence for the development of
um the late heavy bombardment and the
rate of asteroid impacts that we receive
and things like this
anyway to come back to 1625 this this
jupiter-like planet
um had a hint of of something in the
data but what I mean by that is when we
looked at the transit we got the
familiar decrease in light that we
always see when a plant trusts in front
of the star but we saw something extra
just on the edges we saw some extra dips
around the outside
it was right at the hairy edge of
detectability we didn't believe it
because
um I think one of the challenges of
looking for something for 10 years is
that you become your own greatest
skeptic and no matter what you're shown
you're always thinking I've been it's
like falling in love so many times and
it not working out you you convince
yourself it's never going to be it's
never going to happen not for me you
know this just isn't this isn't going to
happen and so I saw that and I I didn't
really believe it because I didn't dare
let myself believe it
but being a good scientist we knew we
had an obligation to publish it to talk
about the result and to follow it up and
to try and resolve what was going on
so we asked for Hubble Space Telescope
time which was awarded in that case that
we were one of those lucky 20 that got
telescope time and we started it for
about 40 hours continuously and
um to provide some context the dip that
we saw in the Kappa data correspond to a
neptune-sized moon around a
jupiter-sized planet which was another
reason why I was skeptical that we don't
have that in the solar system that seems
so strange
and then when we've got the Hubble data
it seemed to confirm exactly that there
was two really striking pieces of
evidence in the data that suggested this
moon was there another was a fairly
clear second dip in light pretty clearly
resolved by Hubble it was about a five
Sigma detection
and on top of that we could see the
planet didn't Transit when it should
have done it actually translated earlier
than we expected it to by about 20
minutes or so and so that's a Hallmark
of a gravitational interaction between
the planet and the moon we actually
expected that you can also expect that
if the moon transits after the planet
then the planet should come in earlier
than expected because the Barry Center
the center of mass lives between the two
of them they're kind of like on a
balancing arm between them and so we saw
that as well so the phase signature
matched up the mass of the moon was
measured to be Neptune Mass
and the size of the moon was measured to
be Neptune radius and so everything just
really lined up and
um we spent months and months trying to
kill it this is my strategy for anything
interesting we just try to throw the
kitchen sink it and say we must be
tricked by something and so we tried
looking at the you know the centroid
motion of the telescope but the um the
different wavelength channels have that
have been observed the pixel level
information and no matter what we did we
just couldn't get rid of it and so uh we
submit it to science and I think at the
time science which is one of the top
journals said to us would you mind
calling your paper discovery of an
exomoon
and I had to push back and we said no
we're not calling it that I don't even
despite everything we've done we're not
calling a discovery we're calling it
evidence for an EXO Moon because for me
I'd want to see this repeat two times
three times four times before I really
would bet my house that this is the real
deal and maybe and I I do worry as I
said that perhaps that's my own
skepticism self-septicism going too far
but
um I think it was the right decision and
since that paper came out there has been
continuous interest in this object
another team independently analyzed that
star and recovered actually pretty much
exactly the same resources us the same
dip the same the same wobble of the
planet and a third team looked at it and
they actually got something different
they saw the dip was diminished compared
to what we saw they saw a little hint of
a dip but not as pronounced as what we
saw and they saw the wobble as well so
there's been a little bit of tension
about
analyzing the reduction of the Hubble
data
um and so the only way in my mind to
resolve this is just to look again we
actually did propose to Hubble straight
after that and we said look if our model
is right if the moon is there it came in
late last time it transited after the
planet because of the orbit we can
calculate that it should Transit before
the planet next time
if it's not there if it doesn't Transit
before and if we even if we see a dip
afterwards we know that's not our moon
it's obviously some instrumental effect
for the data we had a cause or
prediction as to where the moon should
be and so I was really excited about
that but we didn't get the telescope
time and unfortunately if you go further
into the future we no longer have the
predictive capability because it's like
predicting the weather you might be able
to predict the weather next week to some
level of accuracy but predicting the
weather next year becomes incredibly
hard the uncertainties just grow and
compound as you go forward into the
future more and more how are you able to
know where where the move would be
positioned so you're able to tell the
the
orbiting like geometry and and frequency
yeah so from the uh basically from the
wobbles of the planet itself that tells
us the orbital motion of the moon it's
the reflex motion of the moon but isn't
the planet isn't it just an estimate to
where
like I'm concerned about you making a
strong prediction here because like if
you don't get
if you don't uh get the moon where the
moon leads on the next time around if
you did get Hubble time couldn't that
mean something else if you didn't see
that like because you said it would be
an instrumental I feel I I feel
um
the strong urge to disprove your hero
which is a really good uh imperative
it's a good way to do science but like
uh this is such a noisy signal right or
blurry signal maybe yeah low resolution
signal maybe that's but yeah I mean it's
it's a five Sigma signal so that's
that's the slightly uncomfortable Edge I
mean it's often said that for any
detection of a first new phenomena
you really want like a 20 25 Sigma
detection then there's just no doubt
that what you're seeing is real
this was at that edge I mean I guess
it's comparable to the Higgs boson but
the Higgs boson was slightly different
because there was so much theoretical
impetuses to expect a signal at that
precise location
um a neptune-sized moon was not
predicted by anyone no one there's no
papers you can find that expect
neptune-sized moons around Jupiter sized
planets so there was I think we were
inherently skeptical about its reality
for that reason
um but this is science and action and
when we we you know we fit the wobbles
we fit the dips and we we have this 3G
geometric model for the motion of the
orbit and projecting that forward we
were we found that about 80 percent of
our projections led to the Moon to be
before so it's not 100 sure there was
there was maybe 20 of the cases it was
over here but to me that was a hard
enough uh a hard enough projection that
we felt confident that we could refute
the X which was what I really wanted I
wanted a refutable That's the basis of
science a falsifiable hypothesis how can
you make progress on sites if you don't
have a phosphibal testable hypothesis
and and so that was the the beauty of
this particular case so there's a
numerical simulation with the Moon
uh that fits the data that we observed
and you can now make predictions based
on that simulation yeah
that's so cool okay it's fun these are
like little
solar systems that we can simulate on
the computer and imagine their motions
um but
we are we are pushing things to the very
limits of what's possible and that's
double-edged sword it's both incredibly
exciting intellectually but you're
always you're always risking to some
degree the pushing too far so I'd like
to ask you about the uh the the recent
paper you co-authored an excellent
survey of 70 cool giant exoplanets and
the new candidate coupler 1708 bi I
would say this I'd say there's like
three or four candidates at this point
of which we have published two of them
uh and to me uh to a quote uh compelling
and deserve follow-up observations
um and so there are to get a confirmed
detection at least in our case we would
need to see it repeat for sure one of
the problems with the some of the other
methods that have been proposed is that
you don't get that repeatability so for
instance an example of a technique that
would lack that would be gravitational
micro lensing so it is possible with a
new telescope coming up in the future
um called the Roman Space Telescope
which is basically a repurposed by a
satellite that's the size of the Hubble
mirror going up into space it will stare
at millions of stars simultaneously and
it will look to see instead of whether
any of those stars get dimmer for a
short amount of time which would be a
Transit it'll look for the opposite
it'll look to see if anything can get
brighter and that brightness increase is
caused by another planetary system
passing in front and then
gravitationally lensing light around it
to cause a brightening and so this is a
method of discovering an entire solar
system but only only for only for a
glimpse you just get a short glimpse of
it passing like a you know a ship
sailing through the night just that that
one photo of it now the problem with
that is that um it's very difficult for
you know the physics of of gravitational
lensing are not surprisingly quite
complicated and so there's many many
possible solutions so you might have a
solution which is this could be a red
dwarf star
with a Jupiter light planet around
that's one solution but another solution
is that it's a free-floating planet a
rogue Planet like Jupiter with an
Earth-like Moon around it and those two
solutions are almost indistinguishable
now ideally we would be able to repeat
the observation we'd be able to go back
and see well if the moon really is there
then we could predict its mass this
particular motion and expect it to be
maybe over here next time or something
with micro lensing it's a one snapshot
event and so for me it's intriguing as a
way of revealing something about the
examine population but I always come
back to transits because it's the only
method we really have that's absolutely
repeatable that we'll be able to come
back and prove everyone you prove to
everyone that look on the 17th of
October the moon will be over here and
the moon will look like this and we can
actually capture that image and that's
what we see with of course many expert
plants so we want to get to that same
point of full confidence full
confirmation the slam dunk detection of
these EXO moons but
um yeah it's it's been a a hell of a
journey to try and push the field into
that direction and
um there's some resistance to the
transit method not just the transmit I
just say to EXO means so the transit
method is by far the most what the most
popular method for looking for EXO
planets but um yeah as I've alluded to
EXO moons is is kind of a niche topic
within the discipline of exoplans and
that's largely because there are people
I think are waiting for those slime
dunks and it was like the if you go back
to the first exoplanet discovery that
was made in 1995 by Misha mayor and
Didier colors
um I think it's true at the time that
they were seen as Mavericks that the
idea of looking for plants around Stars
was considered fringe science and you
know I'm sure many colleagues told them
why don't you do something more safe
like study eclipsing stars to binary
star systems we know those exist so why
are you wasting your time looking for
planets you're gonna get this
um alien moniker or something and you'll
be you'll be seen as a fringe Maverick
scientist and so I think it was quite
difficult for those early Planet Hunters
to get legitimacy and be taken seriously
and so very few people risked their
careers to do it except for those that
were either emboldened to try or had
maybe the career uh maybe like a tenure
or something so they didn't have to
necessarily worry about the implications
of failure and so
once that happened once they made the
first discoveries overnight
you know everyone and their dog was
gunning into exoplas and all of a sudden
the whole you know the whole astronomy
Community shifted and huge numbers of
people that were Once Upon a Time
studying eclipse and binaries you know
changed to becoming exoplank scientists
and so that was the first wave of
exoplat scientists we're now in a kind
of a second wave or in the third wave
where people like me to some degree kind
of grew up with the idea of exoplanets
as being normal you know I was 11 years
old I guess when the first exploit was
discovered and so to me it was a fairly
uh normal idea to grow up with
um and so we've been trained in the
exoplanets from the very beginning and
so that brings a different perspective
to those who have maybe transitioned
from a different career path
um and so I suspect with EXO moons and
probably techno signatures uh
astrobiology many of the topics which
are seen at the the fringes of what's
possible
they will all open up into becoming
mainstream one day but every there's a
lot of people who are just waiting uh
waiting for that that assuredness that
there is a secure career net ahead of
them before they commit yeah it does
seem to me that Exxon moons open
wider or open for the first time the
door to to aliens so more seriously
academically studying all right let's
let's look at like alien worlds like so
uh I think it's still pretty fringe to
talk about alien life even though like
on Mars and the moons and so on you're
kind of like
you know you'll be nice but imagine the
first time to discover a living organism
that's gonna change
then everybody would look like an idiot
for not focusing everything on this
because the the possibility of the
things it's possible it might it might
be super boring it might be very boring
bacteria but even the existence of life
elsewhere yeah some I mean that changes
everything that means life is everywhere
yeah if you knew now that in five years
ten years the first life would be
discovered that was where you need that
in advance it would surely affect the
way you approach your entire career as a
especially someone Junior in astronomy
you would surely be like well this is
clearly going to be the direction I have
to dedicate my classes and my training
and my education towards that direction
all the new textbooks all the yeah
that's right written I mean uh and I
think there's a lot of value to hedging
like allocating some of the time
to that possibility because the kind of
Discovery will the kind of discoveries
we might get in the next few decades
it feels what like we're on the verge of
a lot of getting a lot of really good
data and having better and better tools
that can process that data so there's
just going to be a continuous increase
of the kind of discoveries that will
open like but a slam dunk
that's hard to come by yeah I think a
lot of us are anticipating I mean we're
already seeing it to some degree with
Venus and the phosphine incident
um but we've seen it before with Bill
Clinton it's in the White House lawn
announcing life from Mars and they're
they're inevitably going to be spurious
claims or at least claims which are
um ambiguous to some degree there will
be for sure a high profile Journal like
nature or science that will one day
publish a paper saying buy a signature
discovered or something like that on
Trappist one or some other planet and
then there will be years of back and
forth in the in the literature and that
might seem frustrating but that's how
science works it's in it that's the
mechanism of science at play of people
scrutinizing the results to intense
skepticism and it's like a crucible you
know you burn away all the relevances
until whatever is left is the truth and
so you're left with this this product
which is that okay we either believe or
don't believe that by signatures are
there so there's inevitably going to be
a lot of controversy and debate and
argument about it we just have to
anticipate that and so I think
you have to basically have a thick skin
to some degree academically to dive into
that world and you're seeing that with
um with phosphine it's been uh it's it's
been uncomfortable to watch from the
outside the kind of dialogue that some
of the scientists have been having with
each other about that because
um they get a little aggressive yeah and
you can understand you can understand
why because jealousy I don't know I
that's me saying that you that's me
talking
I'm sure there's I'm sure there's some
envy and jealousy involved
um on the on the behalf of those who are
not part of provisional Discovery sure
but there's also in any case just leave
you know the particular people involved
in Venus alone in any case of making a
claim of that magnitude yeah especially
life because life is pretty much one of
the biggest discoveries of all time you
can imagine scientifically
um you can see e and I'm so conscious in
myself when I get closer as I said even
the much smaller goal of setting an EXO
Moon the ego creep in
and so as a scientist we have to be so
guarded against our own egos you see the
lights in your eyes of a Nobel Prize or
yeah
um the the fame and fortune and being
Remembered in the history books and we
all
grew up in our training learning about
Newton and Einstein these Giants of the
field fireman Maxwell and you get the
idea of these individual contributions
which get immortalized for all time and
that's seductive it's why many of us
with a skill set to go into maybe
banking instead decided actually there's
something about the idea of being
immortalized and contributing towards
Society in a permanent way that is more
attractive than the financial reward of
applying my skills elsewhere so to some
degree that ego can be a benefit because
it brings in skillful people into our
field who might otherwise be tempted by
money elsewhere
but
on the other hand it the closer you get
towards when you start flirting with
that Nobel Prize in your in your eyes or
you think you're on the on the verge of
seeing something you can lose
objectivity
a very famous example this is uh Barnard
star there was a planet claimed there by
Peter Van de Camp I think was in
1968-69 and at the time it would have
been the first ever EXO ever claimed and
um he he felt assured that this planet
was that he was actually using the
wobbling star method but using the
positions of the Stars to see them to
clean this exoplanet
it turned out that this planet was was
not there subsequent analyzes by both
dynamicists and theorists and those
looking at the instrumental data
established fairly
um unanimously that there was no way
this planet was really there but Peter
vanderkamp insisted it was there despite
overwhelming evidence that was occurring
against him
um and even to the day he died which was
I think like nine in the early 90s he
was still insisting this planet was
there even when we were starting to make
the first genuine exoplank discoveries
and even at that point I think Hubble
had even looked at that star and had
totally ruled out any possibility of
what he was talking about and so that's
a problem how do you get to a point as a
scientist where you just can't accept
anything that comes otherwise because
you're it starts out with the the dream
of Fame and then it ends in a stubborn
refusal to ever back down of course the
flip side of that
sometimes you need that to have the
strength to carry a belief against the
entire scientific community that resists
your beliefs
and so it's it's a double-edged sword
that can happen but it I guess the
distinction here is evidence yes so in
this case
the evidence was so overwhelming it
wasn't really a matter of interpretation
it was it was you had to collect you'd
observe this star with the same
um the same star but with maybe 10 even
100 times greater Precision if it
prolonged much longer periods of time
and there was just no doubt at this
point this planet was was a mirage
and so that's why you have to be very
careful I always say don't ever name you
know my my wife and my daughter like
name this planet after me that you
discover and I can't I can't ever name a
plan FDA because I'll be I won't be
objective anymore how could I ever how
could ever turn around to you and say
that planet wasn't real that I named
after you so you're somebody that talks
about and is clear in your eyes and in
your way of being that you love the
process of discovery that Joy the magic
of just uh
you know uh seeing something a new
observation a new idea right
um but I guess the point is when you
have that great feeling is to then
switch on the skepticism like to start
like testing
um what does this actually mean is is
this real what are the possible uh
different interpretations that could
make this a lot less Grand than I first
imagined and yeah all so both have the
wander and the skepticism all in one
brain yeah I think the generally the
more I want something to be true the
more I inherently doubt it and I think
that just comes from you know I I grew
up
um with a religious family and was just
sort of indoctrinated to some degree
like many children are that okay that's
just normal that you know there's a
garden this is the way the world is uh
God created the Earth and then as I
became more
you know well read and illiterate of
what was happening in the world
scientifically I started to doubt and it
really just struck me that the hardest
thing to let go of when you when you do
decide not to be religious anymore and
it's not really a like a light bulb
moment but it just kind of happens over
my over sort of 11 to 13 I think for me
it was happening but it's that sadness
of letting go of this beautiful dream
which you had in your mind of eternal
life for you know for for behaving
yourself on Earth you would have this
beautiful Heaven that you could go to
and live forever and that's very
attractive and for me personally
um that was one of the things that
pulled me against it was this it's it's
like it's too good to be true and it's
very convenient that this could be
um this could be so and I have no
evidence directly in terms of a
scientific sense to support this
hypothesis and it just became uh really
difficult to reconcile my growth as a
scientist and I know some people find
that reconciliation I I have not maybe I
will one day
um but as a general guiding principle
which I think I
I obtained from that experience was that
I have to be extremely guarded about
what I want to be true because it's
going to sway me to say things which
which are not true if I'm not careful
and that's the that's not what we're
trying to do as scientists so you felt
from a religious perspective that there
was a
a little bit of a gravitational field in
terms of your opinions like it was
affecting how you could be as a
scientist like as a scientific thinker
obviously you were young
yeah I I think um
I I think that's that's true that
whenever you're
whenever there's something you want to
be true it's it's the ultimate seduction
intellectually and I worry about this a
lot with um with you know UFOs and with
um it's it's true already with things
like Venus phosphine and uh searching
for astrological signals
we have to guard against this all the
way through from however we're looking
for life however we're looking for
whatever this big question is there is a
part of us I think I would love that to
be life in the universe
um I hope there is life in the universe
but
um I'm somewhat uh been on record
several times as being fairly firm about
trying to remain consciously agnostic
about that question I don't want to make
up my mind about what the answer is
before I've collected evidence to inform
that decision that's how science should
work if I already know what the answer
is then what am I doing and that's not a
scientific experiment anymore you've
already decided so what are you trying
to learn what's the point of doing the
experiment if you already know what the
answer is there's no point